I mean look we had inflation uh while we
had a pandemic
and we had inflation before Vladimir
Putin invaded Ukraine it wasn't caused
by supply chain shortages brought on by
the coronavirus it wasn't because by
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine it
was caused by the Democrats spending
trillions of dollars we don't have and
as I explained not only the strong
Waging War on America's energy
production those are the two main
reasons we have record high inflation
and while so many American families
struggle to make their budgets meet at
the end of the month
when do you think the Democrats as a
party completely tipped over into that
because you know if you think only you
know 40 or 50 years 50 some odd years
ago JFK as a Democrat asked not what the
country can do for you ask what you can
do for the country is is very reverse of
oh just bow to the state all the time
when do you think they actually fully
tipped into what we now see with with
the modern Democrats you see it
progressing steadily from Wilson through
FDR and Truman and then getting to the
60s about JFK I write a lot about
Kennedy and Only the Strong
um no doubt uh he was capable of soaring
rhetoric but it masked a terrible record
um JFK very much subscribed to Woodrow
Wilson's conception of the
administrative State and technocratic
expertise he had all these so-called
best and brightest tinkering with the
economy most especially in the
Department of Defense tinkering there uh
disregarding the wisdom of the men who
had helped win World War II and as I
write in Only the Strong uh you see this
most importantly in Vietnam uh JFK
turned Vietnam into what was a local
conflict in which we had one side South
Vietnam that was capable of fighting and
defending itself with our support but
thanks to his weakness thanks to his
indecision thanks to his belief in his
kind of enlightened scientific tinkering
he and LBJ turned the Vietnam War into
an American war that whose Legacy has uh
distorted the views of America and
turned so many left-wing Democrats
openly hostile against our country then
and since so is there any Democrat
that's left I mean when you're talking
to your colleagues in the Senate I mean
I was a Democrat for most of my life
most of my you know that that's what put
me on the map I was a Democrat I was a
lefty and I started you know seven or
eight years ago saying hey something's
not right here and then I kind of just
followed that path down the road and now
when I look at the Modern Democrats it's
like man there is nobody left that I
think would represent
perhaps a government that maybe would be
a little bigger than you want but not a
completely totalitarian government there
there seems like there's nobody left are
they secretly around I mean do you
privately meet with these people and
they go boy the squad's out of control
but I'm afraid of them yeah I wish I
could say I did they but no uh uh
Democrats like the squad members in the
house are fully in the saddle uh
responding in many cases to the large
activist base of the democratic party I
mean when you think about Democrats who
believe in a strong competent powerful
America the last one I can really think
of is Joe Lieberman and what happened to
him the Democrats voted him out in their
own Primary in 2006. uh people before
him who were somewhat anomalous like say
uh scoop Jackson
um but for a long time there just hasn't
been many strong Democrats now when it
comes time to go to the polls they
sometimes might like to present
themselves as strong or caring about
your concerns in the same way Democrats
have been making a lot of noise over the
last couple months worried about gas
prices but it's all at the side what
they're really worried about is their
own electoral future not about the
future of America
so if we Flash Forward this I know uh
nobody wants to be in the prediction
game especially a sitting Senator but if
we flash forward this to the midterms
that are you know basically in a week or
10 days at this point
I mean
do you sense this red wave that everyone
senses and and what do you think about
sort of the overconfidence feeling that
that you know you got to worry about
well I believe Republicans are going to
win control of the house and the Senate
I don't want to Hazard a guess of how
many seats we'll have but I think most
Americans now are looking
at where their lives are now versus
where they were two years ago they're
making less money they're spending more
money their streets are less safe we've
had five million illegal aliens enter
our country there's a major war in
Europe China now has a new uh an
aggressive dictatoring like anything
that they've had since now who's
shooting missiles over Taiwan I think
they're very worried about the future of
our country and they realized that again
this is not an accident this is not a
mishap it all goes directly to the
Democratic party's choices and in many
cases their intentional desire for
instance see higher gas prices and they
want to check and balance on Joe Biden
yeah it's incredible the the intentions
part of it I'm just so amazed by that
they that they actually say it in front
of us you know we want to end fossil
fuels and then we watch these prices go
up and then they say but the price going
up has nothing to do with us it's all
because of Putin you have to sort of
admire that because then the media runs
covered does that ever does it ever make
you jealous that they have a whole uh
mainstream media to run cover for them
that I would say doesn't Run cover for
guys like you as much
well we have reality on our side I mean
look we had inflation uh while we had a
pandemic
and we had inflation before Vladimir
Putin invaded Ukraine it wasn't caused
by supply chain shortages brought on by
the coronavirus it wasn't because by
Vladimir Putin's invasion of Ukraine it
was caused by the Democrats spending
trillions of dollars we don't have and
as I explained not only the strong
Waging War on America's energy
production those are the two main
reasons we have record high inflation
and while so many American families
struggle to make their budgets meet at
the end of the month so what would you
want uh I almost said Obama who might be
pulling the spring the strings what
would you want Biden to do today if if
you sat down with him today and said hey
this energy crisis we have to fix this
what would you want him to do right now
well I'll write a little bit about this
and Only the Strong because it can't be
stressed enough that that energy
literally Powers America that's why we
call it the power the power Zone oh the
power's back on that's what makes a
difference in Modern Life going back 250
years is the energy we get from sources
like coal oil gas and now nuclear power
as well we have to recognize that those
energy sources are going to power
America for the rest of our lifetime it
is a fantasy to think that wind power
and solar power is somehow going to
replace those sources I mean we still
get seven eight the ball of our energy
from fossil fuels and nuclear power in
America and even among so-called
renewable or clean energy we get a lot
more from water and wood and crops than
we do get from wind and solar combined
so as I write not only strong we have to
to reinvigorate the fossil fuel industry
in America now there's no single thing
that Democrats have done to strangle
fossil fuel production America so
there's no single thing we can do to
help unleash it but there's a lot of
steps we can take
for instance we can start building
critical infrastructure most importantly
new pipelines I was in Western
Pennsylvania a couple weeks ago with MIM
and Oz on the campaign Trail we visited
a natural gas pad there's enough natural
gas in Pennsylvania and Ohio and the
rest of America to essentially replace
all of the energy that we Import in this
country yet New England is paying
sometimes quadruple the rates for
natural gas this winter as the rest of
the country does why because New York
won't let let pipelines be built across
its territory to provide American Gas to
American citizens
think about the LNG liquefied natural
gas that we could export to other
countries wouldn't it be better if
Europe was relying on America for
American Gas rather than Russia for
Russian gas
look at the amount of Permitting that
has not occurred on federal lands which
is almost 30 percent of this entire
country to allow oil and gas exploration
or federal waters so there's a lot of
steps we can take to make sure that the
federal government is encouraging and
promoting energy production in this
country some of those are also simply
rhetorical or even economic you know
there are many left-wing banks on Wall
Street that are part of the Democrats
campaign against fossil fuels in America
we should be celebrating the fact that
we have
Roughnecks and coal miners who are
helping achieve energy Independence here
and providing energy to our allies
around the world we shouldn't be trying
to cut them off from access to the
credit and the equity markets if we take
those steps if Biden would simply
appeal to sanity when it comes to our
energy sources here in America we can
bring gas prices down we can bring your
electricity bills back down and we could
help rebuild American power around the
world as well if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell